a lot of kids is [ __ ] jet it just
start working you know yeah yeah or just
getting like especially if their family
had a job or something like that
what kind of work did you get into I did
cement work I did building decks
construction work and then I when I was
18 I got a decent job with the buildings
distribution company yeah and we would
go to job sites and like deliver doors
and just brand new houses so everything
they need trim doors windows I did that
for a couple years yeah and did in at
one point do you were like man this
isn't for me
I was fighting during those so you
already fight yeah I was fighting when I
was 18 but I did that and I had benefits
at the place so I didn't want to quit
the job cuz you know yeah with you yeah
yeah okay so yet it support that yeah
yeah but I was making like such little
money that I was just working because I
needed the benefits and I was fighting
so yeah you know damn I was still
working I was still working when I was
fighting the WC I think even in the UFC
I was still working was durin not wizard
what was that moment like we're like
okay now at least make hadn't have
enough income where I don't have to do a
side job was that that was huge part of
my life yes I was like I'm finally but
you know people run around and say
they're professional fighter but they
don't really feeding their family and
paying their bills being a professional
fighter yeah they already yeah right
it's like you see kind of say you are
for a long time but until somebody sees
you walking on a real stage on
television or something it's just like
but even then I was on television I was
still working you know yeah but when I
got to finally walk away from my work
and commit a hundred percent to fighting
it was it was a you know fell like the
sky opened up and the Sun was shining on
me like we made it you know we we really
have a chance at this that's crazy and
the wildest thing about your profession
like at least you know and it's so many
professions you can kind of be anywhere
you know there's a billion lawyers you
know and there's a billion you know
there's and there's tens of thousands of
comedians but in your profession there's
only like it just keeps getting smaller
towards the top until you have the strap
right yeah man there's you know lots of
fighters nowadays is such a popular
sport yeah and it's not like we find out
who the best is you know we fight each
other and find out what the best is so
that's a pretty cool way to uh you know
filtering out everything yeah when you
look back at like a fight that you if
you could have another fighter do one
over it could even be one that you won
or it could be one that you didn't do
you have any that pop in your head that
you're like oh that one
um one that sticks out for sure is the
kind of McGregor fight I just way too
emotional yeah I just cared too much
about everything going on and read too
much about what people thought and it
was he a celebrity at that point really
no not really I mean what he was right a
lot of people you had a lot of hype
around them but he wasn't the guy years
now you know right yeah now it's almost
like he's uh yeah now he's more of a
celebrity or if you then a fighter or
not more than but it's an equal yeah and
it's different it's different when
people become that or I notice anywhere
I can stand up like Dave Chappelle will
come into the comedy club and he's like
a celebrity you know and he gets on
stage and he'll and he's a funny guy but
he's but if bill burr comes in bill burr
is a comedian like bill bird does his
[ __ ] job he murders every time like
Chappelle is a little bit more like oh
look at me
we're bill burr is like sneaks in does
is [ __ ] work really good and leaves
you know feel that um for the love of
the craft yeah yeah do you start to see
that in your in your line of work to
like some guys when they become
celebrity like it seems different
yeah people change for sure you start
making money people start running up to
him for autographs and they start
getting that you know recognition in
public and stuff people change for sure
yeah the egos dangerous huh yeah man do
you worry about that no cuz I'm in it
for the scrap you know yeah I try to
walk away from that type of stuff you
know how right I think if I see a bunch
of guys wearing you have C shirts out
with the hoodie on and I kind of turn
you know yeah you just want to win the
belt yeah I just want to win the belt
man that's all I want I just want to be
the world champion and then I'll go back
to delivering windows so is that is that
really that goal I mean is that so
that's the thing that's the you just
want to be the best yeah of course I
would I would love to stay in the sport
for a long time and make a shitload of
money but I just want to say that I did
it I want to have the UFC championship
around my waist you know all these years
with my wife
struggling and and taking food out of
the out of the grocery basket because we
couldn't afford it and making ends meet
and and you know sacrificing a lot I
just want to say it was all worth it
because once you become the world
champion you know that's forever yeah
and you know that's that's what I'm
trying to do honestly
that's powerful man that's really really
cool it's so in school you know it's
crazy as my sister can't even read but
what does it have to do with us right
now hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one